[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
attorneys for lori valo and chad daybell
want the prosecutor removed from the
case
why a new secret recording is causing
outrage in the case
of two dead iowa children there are some
really
like bombshell moments in that recording
that we may or may not ever
hear and police body cam video captures
the suspect's statements
just after the death of a mod aubry what
travis mcmichael said
after the shooting just don't look good
i mean
plus we break down two sentencing
hearings
one for a man convicted of impersonating
a missing illinois boy
our exclusive interview we felt terrible
terrible for the family it was a
horrible thing that he did to them
and the sentencing for a kentucky man in
the killing of a mother of four
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
another strange twist in the saga of the
so-called doomsday cult couple
lori valo and chad dabel
the bodies of seven-year-old joshua jj
vallo and sixteen-year-old tylie ryan
were found after 10 months of unanswered
questions
lori vallo is charged alongside her
husband chad dabel
after the children's bodies were
discovered on chad's property
now their defense is accusing prosecutor
rob wood
of misconduct after a secret audio
recording between wood
and two witnesses reached the defense
team valo and day bell's attorneys are
requesting to remove wood
from the case law and crimes executive
trial producer
kathy russon explains
rob interviewed two witnesses lori's
sister summer and alex cox was laurie's
now deceased brothers
widow zulema in arizona
they're saying he violated rules they're
accusing him of prosecutor
uh misconduct but the way this came
about is the
there was one attorney garrett smith
that represents both those women in
arizona
he has now said he recorded that
conversation in that interview
and that he was disturbed by some things
that rob wood said so he sent the
recording to mark means
lori's attorney rob wood said he had no
knowledge of being recorded
um he didn't know he's being recorded he
claimed he says he's done nothing wrong
he's filed an affidavit saying
he was contacted by the women's attorney
garrett smith to come down and kind of
have a meet and greet with these two
witnesses
and that he did that and that he left
and then the women were interviewed by
arizona law enforcement he what he said
he wasn't there for that part of it
parts of the recording transcripts were
filed before the judge sealed them kathy
russon has more on what's in them
prosecutor rob wood allegedly was saying
things to summer lori's sister like your
sister's going to be charged as an
accessory to murder
this could be a death penalty case he
allegedly in that recording talks about
how
chad dabell is the mastermind behind all
of this but he has
his best evidence against her sister
lori so
there are some really like bombshell
moments in that recording that we may or
may not ever hear
and i will say that part of what we know
that is in that recording
is apparently rob wood is like demeaning
mark means
saying that he's in over his head some
this is i'm all paraphrasing
but he didn't have co he didn't have
nice words to say about mark means
so that part's interesting rob wood also
says
the part of the recording that he heard
was not the full conversation
that was had and he believes it's been
altered or edited in some
fashion if we believe what is in that
recording prosecutor rob wood told
summer that her sister is going to be
charged as an accessory to murder so
other than that we have not heard
nobody's been charged
in the murder of these two children that
remains were found buried in chad del
debell's backyard in june and nobody's
been charged with their murder
so you have to assume those charges are
coming down at some point
this case has already been full of
secret recordings like one of lori valo
at a meeting
talking about her now dead third husband
i went through a lot of years of of this
kind of hard stuff
and i was going to murder him
i was going to kill him like the
scriptures say like
nephi killed it just to stop the pain
and to stop him coming after me and to
stop him coming after my children
and i was just
i just thought i couldn't take it
anymore and i would go through the
scriptures and find all the things like
if he comes against you once if he comes
against you twice if he comes against
you three times then you can kill him it
says it in the scriptures
there it is there's my answer i don't
want to do anything that's wrong
i did not have a murderous heart
i just wanted to stop the bleeding
joining me now is criminal defense
attorney julie renneman along with terry
austin
julie as a former prosecutor tell us
your thoughts on what you've heard so
far on these allegations of coaching a
witness
so i haven't heard much i mean obviously
we haven't seen the video uh the audio
tape and
and until i hear or at least see some
type of transcript
i'm not really sure this is adding up to
anything it's not unusual for a
prosecutor to inform
witnesses of the potential of people in
their life being
potentially charged with the crime i
don't think that that in and of itself
is any type of prosecutorial
prosecutorial misconduct keep in mind it
sounds like there was
an attorney present during this entire
thing
and so i'm not sure that the fact that
he had those type of conversations adds
up to prosecutorial misconduct
on the other hand obviously the attorney
thought it was something unusual because
he not only audioed but then he provided
it um
to valo and dabel's attorney so maybe
there is more there
who knows i i'm hoping we get to hear
the audio at some point
and terry how do you think the judge
will handle this secret recording
you know brian i think the judge should
deny the motion and here's why i think
that
prosecutor robert wood didn't do
anything wrong
it's not like he's the prosecutor in the
robert durst case if you remember that
case
john lewin really got very involved and
could have been called as a witness here
i don't think the prosecutor was doing
anything like that he was just
investigating the case he had a little
chat before his investigator
started the questioning and garrett
smith
the attorney for the sister and
sister-in-law was there the whole time
so i think the motion should be denied
yeah of course we got to still look like
julian tara is saying into that
recording maybe even the transcript
still ahead on law and crime daily how
police realize an imposter was claiming
to be a missing boy
the exclusive interview you don't want
to miss but first
a deeper dive into interviews of the
defendants in the ahmad arboring case
what the suspects had to say just after
the shooting of an unarmed jogger
through a georgia neighborhood
we're giving you a closer look into
newly released police body cam video
of the moments after the shooting death
of a mod arbory
investigators say gregory mcmichael
started chasing aubry
as he left a construction site son
travis mcmichael
is accused of firing the shots a third
man william rhodey bryan
is charged with boxing arbory inn while
filming the incident
police interviewed the suspects on
camera after they were called to the
scene
just there okay if he would have stopped
that's fine
that's fine like i said just take a
breath here
you got your id and all that no no don't
don't get blood all over yourself it's
amazing i get that your pants are uh you
need to move around do what you need to
do man
that's i can only imagine
yeah anybody who wants to call for you i
live right there i was
we've had break-ins okay and my gun's
stolen
okay and uh we caught him the other day
and that was outside and saw him running
running by the neighbor's point and
everything so he saw who running by him
okay so he ran out to stop him to talk
to him
stop he come out of the truck running at
us i told him stop stop stop till he hit
me
i had nothing to do nothing else i can
do
father greg mcmichael was also in the
truck and described the shooting
from his vantage point the guy turns
around
and starts running back this way roddy
pulls out in his truck and kind of
blocks him
so i said travis go back that way storm
will go hit him off
so sure enough he comes around we come
back down here and he's right here
and he starts he starts running past us
the traps it backs up and says hey stop
stop we want to talk to you
or something to that effect i don't
remember because that works that was all
i said i mean by this time i'm in the
back of the truck
so the guy i mean he's looking dead at
us you know i mean he's like me to you
and he turns he runs travis gets out
with the damn shotgun
and runs up there and you know i said
travis don't don't
shoot don't do anything the guy turns
and comes at him
and they start wrestling the travis
shoes and around the damn chest he had
the guy was trying to take the shotgun
away from it he's got it on video
okay all right do me a favor hang tight
yeah
let me go uh let me go i would like to
get his blood out i roll i understand
that
to check the to check his pulse yep or
didn't roll him i pulled his
hand out money because he had his hands
stuck up under his head i pulled his
arm out and then i realized didn't have
anything in his hand
and saw that this this ain't gonna last
long
so is there any way i can just give me
just a second
sure let me get some pictures and stuff
like that sure and and we'll get
everything around here give me just a
minute you know i was chief investigator
with the da's office
okay three years so i know what you got
to do i know everything
you know back with me our attorneys
terry austin
and julie rendellman terry this newly
released video
infuriates me they had all this
information and these guys weren't
arrested for
months it blows my mind isn't there
enough probable cause to arrest just
based on the videos we saw here
absolutely brian the video demonstrates
more than probable
cause it essentially supports the
highest criminal standard beyond a
reasonable doubt
it's an admission by the father here
that they were both
chasing a mod aubry they cornered him
and frankly he
really states that a mod aubry has no
weapon in his hand
and you know he's telling his son not to
shoot but in fact he does shoot so
i think it is really you know really
horrible that they
took so long to actually arrest the
mcmichaels
now julie the body cam seems like the
perfect piece of evidence for the
prosecution
but what if he wasn't read his miranda
rights first can they still use it at
trial
yeah so i don't think the miranda right
issue is going to be an issue and
and and the reason is is that the
miranda rights are required when someone
is in custody and being interrogated
there's absolutely nothing in this video
that indicates either of them we're in
custody quite frankly
um in in the incident with regards to
the sun the officer approaches him
tells him he can basically do what he
wants for the time being and she
understands what he's going through
and in the other video the father the
officer seems to walk away
so if it's not in custody interrogation
then anything that they say can come in
um and there's no and there's no
boundaries
um to allowing that in i would tend to
agree with you there julian but of
course we're going to see the prop of
the defense try to keep it out some way
don't think it'll be successful but
we'll obviously keep eyes on it
coming up on law and crime daily a
mother found dead
after leaving a bar find out how long
her killer will have to spend
in jail plus sentencing for a man
falsely claiming to be a missing
illinois boy
why investigators still don't know where
this six-year-old is
after the break
[Music]
an ohio man is sentenced to two years in
prison and one year of
probation for impersonating a long
missing boy from illinois
angenette levy spoke exclusively with a
police officer who first interviewed the
imposter
when brian michael rainey showed up in
northern kentucky in 2019 claiming to be
timothy pitzen
it set off an absolute frenzy now rini
is going to federal prison for lying
about his identity
in april 2019 brian michael rini claimed
that he had escaped from a hotel room
and that he had been held captive for
years and sold for sex
mary braun is a cincinnati police
officer who's part of an fbi task force
in cincinnati
she interviewed rene at the hospital he
told the story he would answer questions
but when it came to
the fingerprints and um you know
then of course wanting dna he just was
like i don't like to be touched i don't
want to do any of that and um you know
you still had to be kind of you had to
be gentle because again
what if the one percent chance of this
really was him we certainly didn't want
to re-traumatize him
after talking rini into giving a dna
sample
24 hours later it was confirmed he was
not timothy pitzen
timothy was six when he vanished from
aurora illinois
in 2011. his mother took him on a
two-day road trip
they were last seen on surveillance
video at a hotel in wisconsin
timothy's mother was found later in a
hotel she'd taken her own life
and left a note saying timothy was safe
and would never be found
it was pretty tragic i thought rini
pleaded guilty to one count of
aggravated identity theft in federal
court this week
this marks the third time he's
impersonated a victim of sex trafficking
federal prosecutors said rini caused
unnecessary pain
to the pittson family how could you not
be hopeful i mean i was hopeful
yes i we felt terrible terrible for the
family it was a horrible thing that he
did to them
rini told investigators that he learned
about timothy pitzen's case from
watching an episode of 2020
and that he only wished he had a father
that cared about him as much as
timothy's father
appeared to care about his son rini will
be out next april with time
served and he's been ordered to seek
mental health treatment
for law and crime daily i'm angelette
levy thanks anjanet
terry rini apologized at the hearing and
said he wished he could take it back
does the sentence to you at least uh
make sense for the crime he's accused of
or convicted of i don't think it makes
sense i think he should have a
longer sentence and a longer probation i
understand that he definitely has some
mental illness
and he should absolutely get some
treatment for that
but you know there's no question that he
caused unnecessary pain to the family
impersonating
someone who is missing is a horrible
crime and
in fact if you think about it he took
time away
that the police could have been really
working on other cases here
so i definitely think he got off easier
than he should have
now julie maybe it's the bleeding heart
public defender in me
but i listen to this case i see no one
physically harmed
absolutely emotionally harmed there's no
love loss for me and rini
but two years in jail i would have
thought maybe five years probation and
some mental health evaluation
would have been more appropriate what do
you think well it sounds like he's
getting out in
in april so he's not going to serve the
the full period of time i tend to agree
with terry although i don't think that
he should be serving more time i think
the time that he was given is
appropriate
i think one of the things that stood out
to me in this case is this is not the
first time
he has tried to impersonate someone i
think this is the third time he's done
it so he certainly hasn't learned his
lesson
and i agree with terry that it's not
just the family that suffers
when they believe this person comes back
and there's someone that they've been
waiting to see
forever but it takes time from the fbi
who could be work
and other law enforcement agencies that
can be dealing with
pressing matters instead of dealing with
this absolute nonsense i do think mental
health
does play a role certainly in in
mitigating
his actions absolutely but when we come
back
sentencing in the case of a missing
mother found murdered in a shallow grave
the plea deal her killer accepted after
the break
[Music]
a sentencing hearing for a kentucky man
convicted of killing a mother of four
savannah spurlock was last seen on
january 4th 2019
leaving a bar in lexington police
released these photos
of her leaving a bar with three men a
neighbor reported a foul smell
coming from the home of the parents of
one of the men who investigators say
is of david sparks spurlock's body was
found naked in a shallow grave
wrapped in garbage bags sparks agreed to
plead guilty earlier this month
her family was not yet ready to speak in
court
there will be victim impact statements
forthcoming i know the family
wanted more time to work on them and i
spoke with the court earlier and i'm not
sure they're
really their relevance at this stage
given the
the uh prohibition on on his probation
and
those type of decisions so we'll be
getting those soon and once i get them
i'll forward
to miss roland and to the department of
corrections
okay um under the statute krs 421.520
it says that those victim impact
statements are to be received prior to
sentencing
and if they're not received prior to
sentencing then the family under
krs-421.53
will be given an opportunity to provide
those to the parole board but anything
that's not in the record today it would
be inappropriate to
put anything additional in the record
after today which sims doesn't matter to
you whether it's in this record or just
uh can go to the parole board that's
really all
their concern is is it nonsense that's
correct your honor that's all
the commonwealth is concerned about
getting to the parole board
the judge then sentenced sparks to the
maximum of 50 years in prison
this was resolved by plea two weeks ago
and mr sparks you agreed at that time
plead guilty to the charges of murder
tampering with physical evidence and
abuse of a corpse
recommendation to commonwealth was 50
years on the murder five years on the
tampering
12 months on the abuse of the corpse all
concurrent for a total of 50 years
i will uh accept that recommendation and
impose that sentence
all right so terry 50 years for murder
that number seems to make a little bit
more sense
what's your reaction to the 50-year
sentence you know brian i don't think
that's nearly enough maybe i'm leaning
to the right too much here but when you
consider the fact he's going to be
eligible for parole in 20 years and he
could theoretically
get out when he's like 45 years old i
don't think it's enough i mean obviously
if he stays in jail for that long
it could be deemed enough and i think
that the family here doesn't really
want a trial and they want this to go
away so i understand
but i think that it is really a great
deal for the defendant here
well it's interesting looking ahead to
the parole board julie what do you make
of the family's
uh i guess idea or process of saving
uh their hearing testimony to that of
the parole board
and do you think he's getting out after
20 years after the judge hears
that statement so you know it's an
interesting i guess
tactic um i think it will matter more at
the parole
um point in time because he's getting
the sentence right now regardless of
what
uh the family writes i will add
something to terry because
i agree with terry that i seem to be
leaning the same way she is today and i
think this is not nearly enough time the
one thing that stands out in this case
that makes it unique is that no one
seems to know the exact cause of death
of this woman and one wonders if the
fact that there's
questions as to how she died is the
reason that the prosecutors
ended up giving what i think is an
incredible deal to this defendant
um maybe time will tell in terms of
whether we find that out
and do you think do you think he'll get
off on parole when he first comes up to
the parole board uh
julie i don't think that there's a
chance in the world
based on what we know so far that he's
getting out and i
can be confident that every single
member of this young woman's family and
friends will be there to make sure that
does not happen
thank you terry and julie for joining us
and thank you for joining us here on law
and crime daily we'll see you next time
to discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you